but how do you stay focused I stay
focused very easily
I'm completely utterly 100% driven by
gratitude
I'm extremely aware of where I was born
I mean guys I was born in the most
communist country at its height and I
was the most capitalistic kid ever born
right I had no chance of leaving the
Soviet Union nobody did
in all those years no but nobody left
Russia guys what happened was there was
a singular little moment when Russia had
a food problem because they made a lot
of bad decisions over all I did and they
traded Russian born Jews to America and
Israel that made a pact where America
traded wheat for Jews
I was traded for wheat and was able to
get out of the Soviet Union 1978 insane
so I'm very grateful I'm very grateful
for the fact that I have incredible
parents I've got very fortunate DNA I
suck at 99% of the things in the world I
just happen to be good at one of the
things that really matters which is how
to make money right it's a good thing to
be good at right I mean it I really
really struggling almost everything but
I'm
I'm not your nor it's one of the good
things to have for sure and so I'm just
driven by gratitude I'm super aware that
we only have one life you know from what
I know and I'm super where that I was
gifted with something that matters that
I could communicate that I can pack
others while benefiting myself I'm super
grateful
it keeps me very laser focused you know
very laser focused I am [ __ ] thankful
man
you